welcome back everyone to another vegas
recap i know it's been
a month or two right two months
it's been two months
since i played the national open in
vegas
uh it was end of june
and i started doing recaps on my channel
i have a playlist with rounds one
through four
so if you missed the previous ones feel
free to go back and watch
but in this video i want to show my
round 5 game
which was one of my best games of the
tournament
it featured a really cool opening which
i've never encountered before
and then like very positional strategic
middle game and then like a really
tactical
kind of exciting finish
i do have a picture to show of
right when the game started i was
playing a young talent from the us via
vidyarthi
whose feed rating is around 2300
and he actually beats grandmaster andrew
tang in the first round
so i knew he's uh very capable of
defeating stronger players
and i definitely didn't want to let my
guard down in this game
so before we get into the game this is a
sponsored video and i do want to thank
today's sponsor which is skillshare
thank you so much to skillshare for
sponsoring today's video if you're not
familiar with them they are an online
learning community with thousands of
classes ranging from web design
photography
video production productivity
now one class i took recently that i
really enjoyed is called essentialism by
greg mcewen it really opened my mind up
to what i should prioritize in my
day-to-day life and how to kind of cut
out the non-essentials and improve my
productivity my overall satisfaction
with the work i'm doing
so i do have a special offer for my
subscribers the first 1000 people to
click the link in the video description
we'll get a one month free trial to
skillshare so you can start learning and
exploring everything the platform has to
offer
and with that let's get back to the
chess
before the round started pairings went
up maybe about 20 or 30 minutes before
so
usually when that happens i'll go
straight ahead and look up my opponent
and scout out their opening repertoire
and i knew that
my opponent is a very avid job london
player
which is what he played in this game job
of london being knight c3 and bishop f4
main difference between jobava london
and traditional london is usually
night commits early to c3
and traditional london of course upon
like it's a pawn triangle with e3 and c3
so
i'll admit that
before preparing for this game my
repertoire against jobava london
was very limited
and um i mean i've encountered it many
times uh online i've usually played e6
in the past going for bishop b4
and uh idea c5
um this is actually what andrew kane
went for in round one against uh vyam
and ended up losing vyam was very well
prepared in that game
so i wanted to go for something a bit
different and i went ahead and played c5
which i i prepared for like 15-20
minutes before the round
and here i was expecting white to play
e3
which is a main line and then after
takes takes i was going to play a6 and
try and go for a more positional game a6
prevents knight b5 and then idea for
black is to develop knight c6 bring the
bishop out to f5 or g4 e6 bishop d6 and
just get a playable middle game position
um in the game
vyam played
a much more aggressive move move e4
and
this is a move i had not studied ever
until 15 minutes before the game so i
was fortunate to have looked at this
prior
and it's a type of move that uh
if lacks not prepared things can get
very messy and uh i think there's many
ways black can go wrong or just get a
difficult position
but thankfully i knew what to do um i
took on e4 with a knight
um there's a few other playable moves of
course pawn takes d4 or pawn takes e4
i didn't want to go into this line just
because
white could then choose between d5 just
kind of like a weird amoled counter
gambit position
or white can take and uh
white is really the one kind of
dictating
the future of the game here
so knight takes e4 is a more direct line
and the next few moves are
all pretty much the standard
continuation i take c4 pawn takes e4
white regains the pawn
but now i win this pawn with queen a5
c3 queen take c5 so i'm temporarily up a
pawn but white wins it straight back
with a similar tactic queen a4 check
and queen takes e4
so right before the game i had this comp
this position on my computer screen and
i was still prepared i played bishop to
f5
and here's where my opponent deviated
from my preparation
he played the move queen c4
the only move i looked at before the
game was queen a4
keep in mind and have so much time to
prepare so if i had more time i'm sure i
would have looked at queen c4
um but if white had played queen a4 i
was prepared with kind of an interesting
idea
to play e5
uh attacking the bishop
provoke the bishop back to e3 and then
play queen in d6
and here there's kind of an interesting
positional trap if white plays
one of the most natural moves rook t1
hitting the queen
getting open file then black can respond
with queen g6
and black's already for choice here
because queen g6 friends bishop c2
lacks a bit more developed getting ready
to castle sooner
and uh yeah engine will give like minus
0.3 minus 0.2 ish
so um
i would have liked to go into that
but
after queen c4 i was on my own
and we actually reached a situation
which i think is pretty instructive and
kind of illustrates
the concept of the tempo in the opening
um
it's a situation where i don't want to
take the queen right away because that
only helps white
develop the bishop i would much rather
just defend my queen um and the move i
played is e6 defending the queen with
the bishop
and i want to wait until white takes so
i can develop my bishop
as efficiently as possible
and then we're kind of in a standoff
situation where
white doesn't necessarily want to play a
move like bishop e2
and then lose time after i take and then
bishop has to take
and i don't want to play bishop e7 with
the kind of same thing losing a tempo
so we were trying to find natural moves
that didn't involve
queen takes queen
or developing our king side bishops
uh so i'd start with knight f3
i played rook t8
just trying to improve grab the open
file
and here
vyam finally gave in and took on c5
which is maybe a small inaccuracy i'm
able then to develop my bishop just in
one move
white could have played queen b3
or a4 i think are the top two
engine alternatives but after takes
takes
i was pretty pleased with the position
um of course it's roughly equal queens
are traded nothing too crazy or tactical
just yet
but then white played bishop b5 and was
trying to exert pressure on me as
quickly as possible hitting my knight
and white might have the idea of taking
and just isolating my queenside pawns
so i responded with kind of a
multi-purpose move bishop to e4
not only defending my knight but also
skewering the knight pawn and rook
um i say skewering not to mean like a a
clear tactic but just kind of a
positional pressure along the diagonal
and here's where
whites really try to force matters and
make things
a bit more messy
after the move knight e5
and
this move made me think for a while
of course white is leaving the pawn on
g2 undefended however if i take it light
can respond with rook g1 and this would
actually be a very good trade for white
where g7 is going to fall if i move back
takes
i was calculating this line trying to
make bishop g6 work to trap the rook
but unfortunately the rook can always
survive
after a line let's say knight takes c6
white wins a pawn and if i
try and win the rook white has this move
and pretty sure white's completely
winning here
yeah it's just uh rook's defending and
now my king is one being targeted
so
i didn't go for bishop g2 i went for
the more simple approach just castling
getting out of the pin
and now
now g2 is actually just an undefended
pawn that i do want to take next
so white responded with bishop c6
conceding the bishop pair
but damaging my pawn structure so things
become
a bit more imbalanced here
and now f3 was played
and i'm pretty sure when my opponent
went for bishop c6 and f3
he
was having the idea of just winning a
pawn trying to remove my bishop
from defending the c6 pawn
and
at first i thought i was losing a pawn
too
but then i realized there is a way to
defend it starting with the move bishop
d5
and at first glance this move looks like
a blunder because allows white to play
c4
to
essentially trap the bishop
however
there is a response in this position for
black
uh my opponent did not go for c4 in the
game
i'm just hiding notation so i don't
spoil anything
but uh
if white does go for c4
i want to pose this as an exercise to
the viewers
the bishop's attacked
doesn't really have any useful squares
it can move to the question is
how does black not only save this bishop
but just get a better position so if you
don't see it right away feel free to
pause the video and take your time okay
so we're going to start with the move
that looks like it's almost working but
doesn't quite work
if you thought f6 you are wrong
even though this is a counter attack or
trying to remove the knight from
defending the pawn white has a nice
response knight to
d3
now attacking this bishop this bishop
still attacked let me just confirm this
with engine yeah white is just winning a
full piece here
so
instead of
on f6
there's another kind of tactical
response back in play is bishop takes c4
and what this does is
it does lose the bishop
but thankfully for black i've rook d4
and pretty sure black is winning upon
in the process if bishop to e3 i win the
knight
and black is up a pawn here
real quick i'll check with engine let's
see if white has any stronger response
uh but yeah black is guaranteed to win
one of these pieces and be slightly
better
in the end game
so for that reason my opponent
castle queenside
which
then actually makes the threat of c4
a bit more
dangerous for me because now
i wouldn't have bishop takes c4 and rook
d4 given the rook is on the d-file so i
do have to respond to this threat and i
went ahead and played f6 just trying to
kick the knight away knight retreated
and bishop to b6
and then we reached a position where
even though my pawn structure is a bit
worse than whites
black is still probably the one for
choice just because the bishop pair is
so
useful in the position the center is
relatively open the bishops just control
so many squares they work just very well
together
and it's white who's lacking a bit of
harmony
even though the pieces are are developed
i'm ready to play e5 and uh it's just a
bit more plasmid for black so my
opponent continued night before
trying to pressure my pawn and my bishop
i go for e5
and
yeah in the game i was completely fine
with
lights
getting back a bishop pair or taking
away my bishop pair if takes takes then
i would fix my structure and black would
just have a very pleasant position with
full center king would come in rook
would come in
by no means winning but still pleasant
for black
so after e5 bishop d2 was played
and then i just played the improving
move king f7
i didn't want to move my bishop and lose
a pawn
so
i figured everything's under control why
not improve
uh the king
which
in some cases later in endgame could uh
could be more useful in the center
and here white played
pawn b3 just trying to blunt my bishop
perhaps going for pawn c4
as it turned out in the game b3 did give
me some
more potential to exploit the queen side
as we're going to see in a few moves
and i start with a move a5 here
which not only attacks the knight but
after the knight retreats
i go ahead and play pawn a4
and now we see this pawn chain
even though
it did look stable against the bishop
now it's under serious pressure
i'm just trying to chisel away and if
white were to take i could take on a2 or
put a rook on a1
and
the queen side is uh
is becoming a bit more delicate for
white
so here white responded with c4
i retreated the bishop
and now pawn f4
which we're going to see pawn f4 turned
out to be
a mistake in the game white probably
should have just maintained tension
probably improve the worst place piece
which is a rook just bring it to the
center
and uh and carry on but after pawn f4
this is where
i don't say tactics but this is where my
initiative begins
and we're going to see kind of the
powerful
concept of initiative
or the rest of the game
and for those
who maybe haven't heard of the term
initiative or don't know what it means
it's simply
making continual threats
so if you have initiative you're making
threat after threat after threat
and it turns out that i was able to
continually make threats
or captures
for the rest of the game
and white was never able to kind of get
off the defensive
and the move i sort with is bishop to c7
which is a retreating move but it does
make the threat of simply winning the
pawn
and the other point of this move i
wanted to get off the b-file to then
pressure
uh the b-pawn with eventual rook b8
so white defended on g3
and now i make another threat rook b8
attacking the pawn on b3
and
be very ugly for white to take the pawn
even though this would be a trade takes
on a4 takes on c4
these pawns are incredibly weak the king
is more open now
so white tried to reinforce b3
with knight to b4 obstructing my rook
and
counter-attacking the c6 pawn
but here i play
bishop d6 and this move was played with
a decent amount of calculation which
we're gonna see play out over the board
and of course i leave
my c6 pawn hanging
however i'm more interested in
exploiting white's king and there's
really not too many options here for
whites the knights attack twice
if a move like a3 is played then i just
win b3 and then c4 is hanging
so white's now pretty much committed to
take the pawn on c6 and now try and
weather attack against the king
um so here i
already
felt pretty sure i was winning there
were a lot of different lines to
calculate which i'm gonna try and
explain
but it starts with a very simple check
bishop to a3
um keeping up the threats
and now white only has two options for
the king king c2 and king b1
and when i was calculating this line i
was really excited that there's a
prospect of white playing king b1 which
wasn't played in the game but there's a
nice line bishop f5
forcing the king into the corner
and then i can take
say oh no my rook and then deliver
checkmates with the pawn
so because of this the king pretty much
had to go to c2
and now this line is also
very enjoyable for black
i started with the move rook b6 forcing
the knight to commit to
an uglier square knight has a choice
between
a5 or a7
in both cases we're going to see that
the knight is incredibly misplaced
knight a7 was played in the game if
knight a5 is played i can go ahead and
deliver chuck
king c3 and i'm pretty sure just rook 8
is uh
is just completely crushing here and now
the knight is trapped and just checked
with engine but
yeah white is uh is losing material here
so in the game
my opponent played knight a7
also looks like the knight is
getting trapped on a7 however white's
idea is to play knight b5
and if somehow white can play knight b5
secure the outpost it could be
a very solid kind of defensive setup
with a pawn chain
uh the knight blocking the b file
so going into this line i had to be sure
that my tactics my forcing moves are
working
and turns out there's a really nice idea
which we'll get to but here i start with
pawn takes b3
forcing a takes b3
and now bishop f5
and this is almost checkmate the king
is almost completely dominated by the
bishops as one legal move
king to c3
and now i play
the move rook to b8
uh attacking the pawn
on b3
and
it's very very important to see
the combination for black after knight
to b5 which is not what my opponent
played probably because he saw the the
combination coming
but i do want to pose this to viewers
imagine white plays knight b5
black to move and find the only winning
move
okay so hopefully i gave you enough time
or hopefully you gave yourself enough
time
but the move does involve a
sacrifice
and it involves a really cool mating
that
rook takes b5
oh no my rook but if white takes it
it's checkmate in one
amazingly enough the king just has no
squares
the the bishops the rook upon also is
very clutch controlling d4 all the
squares around the king are controlled
and this would be game over
so
turns out after rook b8 white's just
completely lost even though white's
temporarily up a pawn there's really no
great way to meet the threat of rook
takes b3 which is also a made in one
threat in the game my opponent played
rook b1 which i was kind of disappointed
about i was really hoping for for knight
p5 and to get this main on the board
after rook b1 uh i played bishop b4 not
even taking the rook but i was more
interested in just winning a full bishop
and here light resigned game was
i guess 32 moves
so relatively quick game
but uh overall i was very happy with it
we saw kind of an interesting opening
where i was able to neutralize early got
the bishop pair relatively early in the
middle game
and then
kind of worked up my positional
advantage into a very brutal queen side
attack and then starting with bishop c7
if we just see kind of a
fast motion replay every single move was
a threat
until white uh just collapsed
and essentially either got mated or lost
a lot of material so i really hope you
guys enjoyed that game stay tuned for
more recap videos i know um it did take
a long time for me to make this
schedule's been
pretty busy pretty hectic lately but if
you want to watch the previous ones
again
we have the playlist on youtube i'll
have a few more to record and yeah if
you have any questions about this game
or just questions in general
leave a comment below and i look forward
to seeing you in the next video